They're all happy and it's, and I know why they're happy and it's it's,
there are three kinds of things that I think are that, that make them happy.
And I don't really aspire to them, which is weird, but, um, family, community,
religion. And I think that th I think that like, uh,
people build these inner circles outward. They have themselves,
and they have their family.
Then they have their community and they have religion,
or it might be religion might be the closest thing,
but those are the things I'm not religious, but I understand why it works.
And religious people tend to be incredibly nice and, and,
and forgiving and will help you. And they're,
and part of being religious is actually helping people being charitable.
That's the same thing. And it also bleeds into their family and their community.
So I really liked the title of the book because the,
plus the idea basically that,
that there are positive things out there that you can aspire to,
that you can kind of incorporate in your life and everything else. Um,
we've talked about this a little bit on your show,
but one of the things that I'm kind of amazed by right now is that a certain
set of people. And I would say generally politically they're on the right.
They are actually much happier than the people on the left. Um,
and I don't think that has to do solely with politics or are you with me on
that? Do you see a fundamental reason that even when I just,
just the Fox crew that I've become friendly with, so you and Dana and,
and, uh, Tucker and Hannity, like I, from what I know,
I know you the best happened, but like everyone's happy.
They're all happy. And it's, and I know why they're happy and it's it's,
there are three kind of things that I think are that, that make them happy.
And I don't really aspire to them, which is weird, but, um, family, community,
religion. And I think that th I think that like, uh,
people build these inner circles outward. They have themselves,
and they have their family.
Then they have their community and they have religion,
or it might be religion might be the closest thing,
but those are the things I'm not religious, but I understand why it works.
And religious people tend to be incredibly nice and, and,
and forgiving and will help you. And,
and part of being religious is actually helping people being charitable.
That's the same thing. And it also bleeds into their family and their community.
There is a certain, you know,
possibility or potential for intolerance intolerance as you know,
among religions. And that's always something to be watched out for,
but it provides a structure for people. So I think, but it's true. It's like,
uh, everybody's very happy. Like I am, uh, I am probably more, uh,
uh, I think I,
I swing between poles in terms of happiness and unhappiness because I'm
neurotic. So I, I would say that I'm at my happiest point in my life,
but that's still not as happy as they are because of my neurosis and anxiety
prevents me from jumping completely into the happiness, you know, but.
Greg, as a, as a self-help guru, I can tell you now, uh, that it's,
it's that neurosis, but it's that neurosis that that's sort of creating why,
what you do works because whenever I'm on, on the Greg Gutfeld show,
when we text, after you always say the same thing to me, if it's a good show,
you go, we got all the serious stuff out at the beginning, and then we add fun.
And I think that that's what people are responding to. So it's like your show,
I'm sure, you know, the numbers. I mean,
you are crushing it crushing the late night people right now.
And it's like, they're the ones that have 30 writers.
They've got millions and millions of dollars worth of budgets and all that
stuff. And they're miserable and unfunny. How,
how many people work on your show?
Eight maybe. And, and in terms of writing that show, uh, eh,
we used to do this every night with red eye with roughly the same crew.
And it it's, uh,
like I ride my monologue and then Tom and Holly and this other kid,
gene we'll we'll work on the segments and the graphics,
I'd better not leave anybody out. And of course, cat does her thing,
which is really good and Tyrus writes his stuff. It's um,
and it's naturally funny and smart. And you aren't having, you,
aren't sitting in a air conditioned room with 13 people who are all making six
figures ordering in let's order in and write 40 more jokes for Kimmel's
monologue. Uh, nobody. Right. I mean,
I I'm opening myself up when I say nobody writes my jokes because that's like,
we can tell Greg, but I like,
but I always start with like, okay, I have a serious point to make.
And then you work your way through that. And then at the end,
there are these jokes that come up absurdities. And I,
instead of just leaving them out, I put them in and it always helps to be,
you know, to have targets that are hilarious. I mean, CNN never gets old,
you know, as long as you have Chris Cuomo and Don lemon,
I'm going to have a monologue. And, uh, it, uh, Brian Stelter, I mean,
these are the gifts that, you know, keep on slobbering. Yeah.
Well, that's the thing, because it's like, if you look at the CNN crew now,
not only do they all seem miserable and then we can end the lies and all that
stuff. But like, you guys are having fun. Like there,
there doesn't seem to be any level of fun there.
And I'm not saying the news has to be fun per se, but I think it does.
It does color something else beneath it or something like that.
Think about like the daily show with Jon Stewart was having fun during that
period. I don't see that anywhere. Even on comedy central,
you really don't see any fun. I I've said this to you before. I always use it.
I call it the Dean wormer effect that like,
for the longest time in animal house,
the Republicans were always Dean wormer and everybody else Ludo and the Delta
house, we, the whole goal of when Andrew was alive and,
and, uh, I was working at the Huffington post was to flip it. So yeah,
so the Republicans would be,
at some point would become Delta house and deliver,
and the left would become a Dean wormer. And that's, what's happening. You know,
this, you Dean warmer and you're watching this.
I think I'm curious about how you feel about that tie AB because I feel really
guilty about the,
all the times that I kind of dismissed him as just the left wing will do the way
he dismissed me. I'm sure he didn't even maybe know who I was,
but I see him now. And I go like, he's Dave Rubin,
he's two months away from you becoming right.
I feel like it, you know, it's, it's like a little Pat on my back. It's like,
Oh, all of these people now are just saying what I said years ago. So yeah.
You know, it's like, when you're, when you're ahead of the curve,
you somehow feel behind it in a way when it starts getting to the moment of, of,
uh, mainstream. You're like, ah, but it's good. Like, I don't,
I don't know that he, he knows me specifically, but I'm like, yeah,
you're just writing the same exact stuff I said four years ago. And that's,
that's really great, you know?
Yeah. You see that though. You see that with Bret Weinstein,
you see that with his wife, when you listen to that, what they're,
what they go through. And by the way, probably the most, I guess,
disturbing thing about this last couple of months is that how right Brett
was about, um, what's the name of the biz college green, um, evergreen,
evergreen that would happen in every green. Evergreen has gotten out of the zoo.
It's out of the zoo and, and it's all over the place. And it's like he said,
that was going to happen. And I am trying to maintain a positive,
like this is not going to get any worse because there's no slippery slope with
this. You either, either have law and order, or you don't, you got to stop this.
But so far he's he and his brother had been pretty,
uh, uh, dead on, on this stuff. It makes me very nervous.
So for a guy like you, that doesn't want,
I know you don't want the whole system to collapse, but I think you also,
I think we're probably similar in this way.
You understand the why it's collapsing.
What do you see is the way that we can kind of get out of this thing?
Well, I, I mean, I'm going to sound like a broken record because I am,
I do agree with Donald Trump,
that fake news is the enemy of the people. I mean,
I don't know if you could find a clearer statement than tear down the wall,
maybe, uh,
because almost all of these things that are happening to us right now tend
to be these psychological conflicts that are ginned up.
And I think if you go to any serious issue where there is an issue,
you can talk about police and policing communities, serious issue.
Does the media add or subtract to it? It's a negative, it's a minus.
It's not a plus.
The more that the American public understands how to perceive
what's going on on television, cable, television, and not to trust it,
the better off we're going to be.
I think the first thing we have to do is understand that this is not our friend,
that this, this is a, this is a machinery of division.
That's trying to get us to eat each other alive and they,
and then they don't see it. Like you see on CNN going, you know, we,
this what's happening. They yesterday, you know,
what's happening in Portland is we don't condone it,
but it's being exaggerated, you know, by that pouncing right-wing media, no,
they found a dead body in, in Minneapolis, in a burned out, you know,
a pawn shop that ain't pouncing. That's a corpse. So I mean,
it is,
I think that the first thing is realization that this institution is gone.
It's your enemy. And, and, uh, and I,
and fake news is the enemy of the people sound. So, you know,
it sounds so Trumpy in, but it actually, God, we knew this,
right. We always it's like, like, if you, and by the way, you know this,
I know this specifically because anytime anybody writes about you,
it's never right. It's never, it's like you, you get a, you know,
I've been written about, I don't know, a bunch of times,
and if the person loves your show, it's going to be great.
But if they're coming from a liberal institution in which they have editors,
they can't compliment you. They can't see your point of view.
They can't even empathize.
So they'll go like Dave Rubin claims to be a traditional liberal who became
disillusioned with the progressive left,
what he likes to call it a walking man or regressive,
we met Gabe. And, but, and it's like,
and then there's like six or seven cutting remarks.
And then some comment from somebody who doesn't like you, well,
here's the thing about Dave that you probably aren't aware of it.
And so it builds and you go like, wow,
this whole story was just designed to take me down.
And it's not true.
I didn't say that I've had instances with reputable journalists where I go,
that didn't happen. That didn't happen. And then if you end up on Twitter,
calling people out, you could be there all day. You know, and I,
I I've called out four or five people and they've retracted others don't. But,
um, you know, it's, if you, if you are the object of a story, you know,
this, you knew that, you know how this works, they seek a narrative.
They need to tell a story. If the beach doesn't have a shark, it's not a story.
So they need to have a shark at that beach.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.